From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
What was your awareness or impression of race growing up in Hawaii at that time?
I really didn't have any idea at all because I went to school with different nationalities, Japanese, Filipino, Chinese.
I think there was only one Negro family in the whole section of what they didn't have any children.
It wasn't really until I went to New York that I found out about the racial problem.
I was going to ask, what was it like to go to New York after it was great?
I loved it.
My father was still trying to break up my...
But it's funny the way things are because I went to New York and got into a Columbia University for a standographic session.
And by that time I got a job in my father's house.
Well, if you love New York you've got to support yourself. We've got younger brothers that said, fine.
I went to the employment office and they sent me to the NAACP office, the National Office in New York.
And I think there was a blessing really because I learned about the racial problems only then did I learn about the racial problems.
And I worked for the secretary, for the director of branches of the National Office.
And with that job, I got to meet a lot of the local people.
I went to the conferences in the different cities, annual conventions.
I was always there to take the minutes.
So it was just the pure luck of having the employment office send you to the NAACP?
And the place I think is so good.
I don't know maybe my guardian angels were watching over me.
And that's how I got to meet the secretary of the NAACP, the executive secretary Walter White and Roy Wilkins.
I used to call him Pops and he eventually gave me a way of marriage really to third Marshal.
He was the legal counsel there.
So when you said you were working as secretary of the director of branches, was that Gloster B. Current?
Gloster B. Current, yes.
So can you talk about what some of your day-to-day work was like when you were doing that job?
Well, it was mostly correspondence but we got to meet a lot of people coming into the city for help and going to the annual conventions.
And that's how they got to know me.
You know, when Walter White divorces Black wife and married a white woman that practically broke up the whole organization.
And so when Thurgood proposed, I said no way.
A lot of people still consider me as a foreigner.
How I wasn't too familiar to people then?
I said no way, no. But he insisted. He said, I'm marrying you. I'm not marrying the country and they're not marrying me.
And that's how we got married.
That's interesting.
What was it like to work for the organization when that was happening around Walter White's marriage?
I feel blessed, really, to have been at the organization at that time and learned a lot for myself, really.
And I got to know a lot of the local people in the south especially.
It took us in when we couldn't stay in hotels. We stayed in their private homes and they fed us and treated us like kingsmen.
They themselves, you know, as Serger said, we were cowards. The lawyers were cowards.
Because they'd go into one city, fight their case, argue their case, and take the fastest train and the fastest airplane out.
But he says, the local people put their names on the briefs. They stayed there and met daily opposition, hostile people.
They're the real heroes in the civil rights fight.
Do you remember some of the people that you stayed with? Or, you know, some of the people that you interacted with in the local communities?
A lot of people, I can't remember their names in Atlanta, Georgia, and Chattanooga, Tennessee, and Oklahoma City.
I got to meet a lot of them. And they'd got so that they treated me as a daughter.
I know that there was a lot of hospitality. I've read, I was actually over at the Library of Congress looking at some of the NAACP papers this past week and reading about some of the annual conventions.
What were some of the main issues that you remember typing comments on or working on?
Well, I was there for the cases of Groveland Four, Groveland Four that were indicted because they're so-called right-of-white women or four boys.
I remember Emmett Till case in Chicago. And I don't know so many other cases that were involved, because the branches were responsible for taking care of the cases back.
They got advice from our office, you know, from the lawyers and from my boss, who was hit of all the branches in the country.
So I got to interact with a lot of people.
You must have, while you were in there taking notes, heard a lot of discussions of strategy.
Yes, yes. Did you? What did you?
As I said, it was a blessing for me to learn about our country, the way it is and what's being done.
And as I look back today, we've come a long way. But we still have ways to go.
What do you think are some of the most important changes?
Well, for instance, going to restaurants, going into hotels, without being looked at and without being turned away.
And in some cases, we couldn't even eat in the restaurants. People fed us. We went to conventions there and they fed us.
Believe me, I don't know how they did it. And I remember riding in one car with Thurgood and one of the branch members says,
Judge, open up that dog compartment. He opened up. He says, you see, there's a Bible there and there's a gun there.
He says, we'll use the Bible first. If that doesn't work, we'll use the gun.
That's how they lived. You know, it's remarkable how they did that. I praised them to high.
It must have been really exciting to watch those cases come in and see the victories through that period of the 50s and 60s.
Well, I worked in the branch department, so I didn't have anything to do with the little graphics.
But when they ran short of help for this, the Brown v. Board of Education versus Board, they needed a center graphic help.
And I was there with, well, we were in the same office anyhow. And all the other cases.
I remember reading about a meeting in Atlanta shortly after the Brown v. Board of Education decision and the excitement and anticipation that things would move really quickly.
And then, of course, that's not really what happened. Was that hard to see, too? The resistance?
Well, we celebrated for a while, but after a while Thurgood said, I don't know about you, fools, but our work has just begun.
He was a realist then.
Do you know when he had that moment where he said that or when he thought that, where in the process it was?
When we were celebrating, I think it was the Brown v. Board of Education or one of the big cases.
As usual, we celebrated at the office, but after about an hour, so that's when he said it.
I don't know where he's true, but I'm going back to work or work has just begun.
Well, he certainly was right.
You said that you were concerned about getting married because you didn't want to be perceived as...
Well, I didn't want to break the organization up like the other incident took place, but he said no.
Well, was the response when you got married?
They all loved me. They all thought of me as their daughter really because they've seen me around the branches, conventions.
I was always there taking the minutes, recording the minutes.
So you think it helped the people knew you as a person?
I think it did. I really think so.
Yeah. And not only that working in the branch department, anything that they needed help in the local people would contact the branch department,
the first person they would get to is me, and if I could help them without bothering the director, that's what happened.
And that's how they got to do it. So you were already so bad that they could count on?
Ah, I can't help but...
That was just a nice secret, you know.
Did you get it?
It really has been a lesson for me, myself, and a blessing in a way.
Having been born and raised in Hawaii, you know, you go to school, you learn all the bad words, all the different languages.
Who's this? What do you do, don't you?
It must have been really different, you know, being in Hawaii, where you were with such a mix of people.
And then coming here, where there were so many divisions based on the reason.
Right, it was. It was a lesson to me, really.
Were there particular moments where you first experienced that and began to understand the differences?
Well, I remember about a week after the Brown v. Board of Education, the Henderson v. United States, that was a dining room case, where the dining room was segregated, you know, one section.
There's a section of dining room there with a wall and a curtain there for the black people.
And I remember getting in the train going to Chattanooga about a week after that, with one of the lawyers.
The lawyer always is there to confer with our branches.
Well, he was traveling, and I was traveling along the secretary.
And his name was Franklin H. Williams, one of the lawyers who became a first Negro ambassador to Ghana, if I'm not mistaken.
But he was the lawyer then, and he said, you know, he could pass for anything.
And he said, hey, it's just about you. You know, he asked my boss, who was pitch black, as a matter of fact, they call him Bubo and you know, he only took it from his close friends especially from there.
I can imagine. And he said, no, no, not me.
He was too soon, and the membership secretary was a woman, said, I'm too tired, I just want to rest.
So, Frank said, how about you, says, I said, sure, let's go.
So, you didn't mind traveling, sir?
I was new then, I didn't know that you don't move.
So, we went to the dining car, and the head waiter looked at Frank, he couldn't figure him out.
He looked at me, and he couldn't figure me out with my long hair, flower, my hair.
So, he took us to the table, not, you know, in the partition section, but right next to it.
And Frank looked at him, and he said, poor, call me, you.
And he said, oh, come back this way, and took us to the center of the dining car.
And while we were eating, every time Frank saw the head waiter coming down the aisle, he said, oh, you're there with something in French, and my only French was, we.
And then I went all during the dinner there, but it was quite an experience, because he would look at us, he was still trying to figure out what I was, what he was.
Did you ever feel nervous in those situations?
Never, never.
Now, eat me, come here from Hawaii, you know.
Did you continue to work at the NAACP after you were married?
No, I stopped working in 55, but I kept in close contact, of course, with Thurgood Marshall still being in law, you were there.
What was it like to start seeing all these major events taking place within the civil rights movement? Do you remember the sit-ins and how you felt when they started?
I remember segregation very well, you couldn't go to a different place, you couldn't sit in any place.
I just wish Thurgood Marshall were here.
I just wish to see his work and the work of his lawyers, really, but most of them were gone, like you interviewed Robert L. Carter, Robert L. Carter, one of Thurgood Marshall first assistants there, and Mildred Bond Roxborough Roxborough, she was a few-sector under my boss.
Oh, really?
My boss was the one that hired all the few secretaries for the branch department, and she was one of them.
What was her territory? Where did she travel to?
Well, they tried to travel all over, but they usually go to where they were born and around that area.
You said a little bit ago, you're talking about how much has changed, but some things that are still...
You still get nasty looks every once in a while, and you can feel the difference.
They would serve you, but you can feel the difference.
I don't know if you've been watching the news, but did you follow the cases that were handed down earlier this week, the Shelby County v. Holder?
Yes, in a way, we've made a lot of progress, but I see the court has gone back to some of the few things that invalidated some of the...
But we're getting there.
What was it like to move from New York City to Washington, D.C.? I understand it was still somewhat of a Southern town, then.
Well, from one to the other, I guess I got used to moving then, after New York, you know, what else is new?
Did you get involved in the community when you were here in Washington?
Not too much, because with third of being with legal work and with the NAACP, I have to keep distance.
I had to cut out a lot of my friends as a matter of fact because of the cases involved and so forth.
And parties, you know, you have to be careful.
Is that so that it's not perceived as a conflict of interest?
Yes, yes.
What was it like then for you to have to sort of, you know, because obviously this has a big impact on your life?
Whew! I don't know where to start.
I just feel blessed to have gone through what I did. I learned a lot.
I learned a lot.
What were some of the cases that seemed most memorable to you, either that Justice Marshall was involved in as an attorney or as a justice?
I think the Brown v. Board of Education case was the most important.
And there's so many on this really.
And at my age, this was in the 50s.
You don't want to pull out these cases and sort of rehash them.
Did your brothers and sisters come follow you to the mainland to New York?
Well, not to work, no, but to stay in it.
John W. Marshall, you remember meeting any of my brothers?
No, as a matter of fact, they're all deceased now except for my one sister.
And she's still in her room. She used to teach there.
Do you get back to Hawaii or did you go back very often?
Not too often. It's too long a trip.
You know, five hours to the west coast, another five to Hawaii.
And it's so much easier with the telephone now.
You know, a few cents, but I remember making my first cell phone call, I'm going back in 48 or 49.
My very first cell phone call because I couldn't afford it, $35 a week.
Wow. But I said I was promoting, got $50 a week, so called home.
And we cried, and we cried.
And I got the view of the phone when we began with so I second time I called home,
talk, cry later.
You're not going to cry, I think you're a mother.
You don't want to cry while you're on.
No, I just cry afterwards.
Can you describe what the National Office of the NAACP was like,
like how it was set up and who you were working with?
Well, there was a centographic pool where I started off with.
And then there was a branch department that took, over saw the 1500 branches around the country.
And on the other side was the legal department in the forest to help our branches in their legal work.
And upstairs there was Roy Wilkins at Walter White, but it was like a family really.
After work would sit around for a while and go out to dinner, the few of us.
It really got so, you know, we didn't think of anything except brothers and sisters.
Do you think there was more camaraderie because of the work that you were doing?
Because it felt like it didn't work?
Yes.
Are there some of the people, do you, can you?
I was wondering if you would be willing to describe some of the people that you worked with.
You know, help us get a portrait of people that aren't with us anymore.
Oh, Walter White.
It was a wonderful administrator.
But sometimes he was above all of us.
It was Roy Wilkins that did the work there.
He was the one that met the people locally more often.
And of course, they're good at my boss.
It was like a family really, just like a family, especially when you went to conferences and conventions.
Do you remember some of the places you went for the conventions?
Atlanta, Oklahoma City.
They see Atlanta, Oklahoma City, where else did I go?
Well, we started off in Boston, actually, that was my first convention in 1950.
Then to Atlanta, then Oklahoma City, then Chicago, you knew even Dallas Texas.
And it must have been something else to have people coming from all over the country for the conventions.
And that's how I got to know them because they always had branch problems.
And they would come to my boss and I would be there.
But you have to give them credit really to do what they do in those times.
It's amazing, just amazing.
And the way they treated us, they treated us like kings and queens.
But they didn't have to.
Well, I'm sure they appreciated the help.
But somebody they could call on and somebody they could work with, even while they're struggling where they are.
Especially through our department, actually, the director of branches.
We had to come through our department for any problems.
And we tried to solve them as much as we can before taking it to the board.
Before taking it to the board?
Board of directors for any conflict that we couldn't solve.
What are some of the things that you think young people should know about those days?
That they shouldn't take anything for granted.
It was people in the earlier days that went through all the sacrifices.
They went through all the indignities to build what they are today.
So many people take so many things for granted.
Especially the younger generations.
And you think of the older generations in the south, what they went through.
They were wonderful people.
Did you travel much in the south after the Civil Rights Movement, enough to see some of the changes?
Well, up until 1955.
So you didn't travel after that?
No, no.
So you never married it.
He kept me busy.
And my oldest son, of course, was proud of him.
Can you talk about the church here where we are meeting today?
I think having my deep faith in God was what kept us through.
When you have to have faith in God, you know, you talk to Him in private and just get everything out of the system.
And that is the way I feel.
And that allows you to keep a good up and face things?
Where did you live when you came to New York?
Where did we leave you on 123rd Street?
501 way, 123rd.
We were first leave at 409 Edgecombe Avenue, which was supposed to be the high society of the Negro world.
Then they built a co-op.
The first co-op, middle income co-op in New York, that was what they call Morningside Gardens.
And it was wonderful.
We didn't have to go out to part because they all came to us because we had the two young boys and they didn't have any.
It was easier for them to come.
Can you describe what that living in that community was like?
We had so many friends.
There was Edward R. Dudley, who became ambassador to Liberia the first ever before Franklin H. Williams.
He lived across the building and there was a doctor there.
I can't think which was my husband's doctor.
It's so convenient.
Robert L. Carter, one of the lawyers lived in another.
There were five buildings there.
But we were all within one community.
We lived in one building.
We had Richard Parrish, who was the director of the urban league.
They were above us and we had George Dockery.
He was a dentist.
And between George Dockery's wife and Richard Parrish's wife, they tried to buy the boys' attention.
So one would sneak up and leave food at the front door for the boys.
Then we'd come home again another time and it was food from the yard.
They would try to outdo one another.
They were going on.
They were wonderful, wonderful.
And Louis Jefferson, who was a great artist, lived there.
So it sounds like it was quite a community.
It wasn't just a place to live.
It was. It was wonderful.
That's wonderful.
I couldn't think of a better place for you.
And I said, we didn't have to go out.
They came because of the boys and you were always easy for them to come.
I read in something that after you moved to D.C., at a certain point, you moved out and became the first people to integrate a white community.
Well, we lived at 64 G Street, which was walking distance to the church.
I still come to this church here.
And then it got so that circuit couldn't stand the steps.
But we did move to another co-op on four streets, which was three stories.
But more steps, and after one year, it's enough.
And we found a thousand Virginia, which is wonderful.
Let me see if.
Okay.
I'll ask you about this.
They said that you moved to the Lake Barcroft.
Lake Barcroft.
That's where we are now.
Okay. And was that a white community before you moved in?
It still is, practically.
Ramsey Clark, who was then Attorney General, lived in Lake Barcroft.
And he says, boss, you have to come and integrate the place.
So we moved from Washington to Lake Barcroft.
But as far as I know, we're still the only family there.
Did you have any trouble when you moved over there?
No, not really. When we first moved there,
saw a bunch of kids came by and they welcomed our boys.
Yeah. Yeah.
So you were the first and still one of the only African-American families.
And yet there's one Asian family.
One Asian family?
Out of 1500. So it's very white.
Well, it's not advertised, you know.
That's another reason.
But people don't move out of Lake Barcroft.
How can you move?
Beautiful home. The lake is there.
Walking distance to the bus.
So it's a lovely location.
Yeah, it is.
Yeah.
There were a list here of some organizations that you were involved in.
I'm told you were involved in the National Capitol Auxiliary.
That's the largest wives.
Okay.
That's a wise up from the district, Maryland, Virginia.
And what kinds of things do you do?
Well, we usually have meetings get together and conscious.
Yeah.
And they honor a Supreme Court wives every year.
So is it?
Then I have the Travelers Aid.
I used to be on the board of Travelers Aid and Board of the Legal Defense Fund.
Yeah.
What do you do as part of those boards?
As part of what?
So when you're on the board of the legal fund and the LASVP legal fund,
what kind of work do you do with that?
Well, we decide on policies, you know, and what cases we should go into and recommend and things like that.
Is that difficult?
Not really.
Yeah.
Are there cases that are memorable to you that you were involved in deciding to go for a role?
Well, really Brown v. Board of Education is the one that we stand out.
So are there things that you can think are important for people to know about your life and about the work and things you've been involved in?
I'm just an ordinary person.
I know this is...
I know that I'm blessed to have gone through what I did, you know, and in those times, and coming from a wall is especially.
Yeah.
There's a quote in one of the history books that I like and it talks about ordinary people doing extraordinary things.
And I think that there's a lot of that in the civil rights movement.
I'm only an ordinary person doing ordinary things.
Very, very modest.
You know, I just feel best and you do what you have to do.
You raise your family and with Thurgood being away a lot, I made it a point to stay home with their children, you know.
Well, thank you very much for being with us.
I know that it's a challenge and that you are eager to get home.
Well, I don't mind it.
I just want to say it's been a blessing.
I think I live a charm life.
Of course, after putting up with John W. Marshall, I want to start.
John W. Marshall doesn't get to be there.
He's a wonderful movie.
John W. Marshall doesn't see them 55 years old.
Oh my god.
John W. Marshall, you're going to speak up?
I'm a younger.
A younger of a year.
Yeah, the younger of my old, no, the son is 57.
Yeah.
Can you imagine?
I was going to say that must be an interesting way to know your age if I'm watching your children.
Well, it's been a challenge.
No, but it's been wonderful, really.
Yeah.
Well, thank you very much.
You're welcome.
Unless you want to ask my son.
He said all.
He was well to begin with Marshall and then became the director of the United States Marshals Service.
And he's now with the Transportation Department.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.